ce que vous diriez à Benjamin Castaldi
je lui ai déjà dit depuis longtemps
si vous pouviez lui parler la face
caméra avec un message quelque chose que
vous vous avez envie de lui dire je
t'aime fils ce que vous regrettez de ne
pas avoir fait avec votre fils Benjamin
Castaldi passé plus de temps vous avez
vu c'est Hanouna l'autre à L'Équipe TV
et les fier en plus elle lui fait
plaisir
ils sont beaux et tout
[Applaudissements]
franchement
il est génial Jean-Pierre sans déconner
comment ça marche la transmission
génétique des gars
non je suis très je suis content il est
13 enfants et j'ai un très beau projet
avec lui c'est vrai ouais ouais j'ai
assez envie de faire un spectacle tous
les deux
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai
les losers magnifiques
bah ouais alors je suis désolé
Benjamin il me vous rendez pas compte
rien c'est pas à loser mais non non
désolé vous êtes fous quoi c'est comme
si tu dis au tennis je sais pas moi
parce que c'est alors j'ai pas l'exemple
voilà
non non mais c'est pas looser vous êtes
fou quoi arrête de arrête de dire que tu
es un looser mais c'est pas grave d'être
à louer je te dis que tu n'es pas il y a
pas de honte au contraire accepter
d'être ouvert excepté d'être un loser
c'est de se dire qu'un jour tu pourras
redevenir un winner mais à ce jour n'est
pas si loin tu sors pas l'odeur
[Musique]
la seule honneur que je sens là c'est
pas celle-là mais non mais j'ai pas j'ai
pas de problème avec ça moi je suis
honnêtement il faut vous savez j'ai fait
j'ai fait beaucoup de travail sur
moi-même et je suis très sérieusement et
non dans la vie il faut accepter les
choses mais regardez en face et quand tu
les regardes en face et que tu les
acceptes il dit voilà il y a des choses
qui ont été parfaites j'ai été à winner
une époque j'ai été un looser mon père
est fier de moi c'est déjà pas si mal
nous aussi on est fier de toi c'est bien
sûr je suis un petit peu ton deuxième
papa bien sûr bien sûr c'est vrai bien
sûr ben j'ai j'ai deux papa dans le
métier j'ai Drucker et j'ai à nous là
ouais c'est pas si mal hein tu vois donc
je sais pas pourquoi il est méchant
comme ça
est-ce que tu te rends compte de la
gueule
en plus c'est vrai en plus c'est vrai la
vérité c'est que Gilles est un amour de
mecs
ne croyez pas du tout le livre que vous
voyez c'est de l'inverse en fait voilà
tu essayes d'acheter mon silence
vous pourriez produire le spectacle
d'ailleurs avec son papa allez on va
passer
non parce que là moi je peux pas c'est
compliqué hein
c'est compliqué en ce moment
c'est compliqué
et son fils
je t'aime bien mais n'exagère
parce que tu comptes faire avec toute ta
famille puisque c'est les dix
commandements
donc
ça va être compliqué plus compliqué
j'aimerais bien échanger ton père et
d'un père un fils ça peut être assez
sympa de nous les gens tu vas lui dire
quoi ton père je sais pas bonjour oui
lui il me dirait bonjour ça fait déjà un
démarrage
je la sens pas mal ouais tu as déjà
commencé à écrire je suis en train de
réfléchir ah d'accord voilà bon écoutez
on verra pas ce projet avant 2028 hein
2024 2024 à 2024 tu es sûr vraiment tu
tu vraiment tu te mets tu as déjà une
idée c'est quoi le pitch le pitch c'est
que moi mon père et moi on a un point
commun c'est que parfois dans nos deux
carrières
au moment où ça au moment où ça devait
arriver PIM on attribuait donc ça c'est
donc
mon père
va vous dire une chose après mon père à
23 ans il était appelé par la Warner les
parties on aimerait qu'on sert un film
aux États-Unis aux États-Unis il avait
un rôle extrêmement important il peut
faire un film que américain et et sa
mère à l'époque qui tirait les cartes
lui a dit Jean-Pierre tu pars en
Amérique mais tu ne tourne pas
arrête tes conneries j'ai le billet
d'avion donc là c'est la parabole
d'ailleurs donc la parole du renvoie le
billet d'avion le contrat signé il part
en première classe il fait un prêt à la
banque parce qu'il achète plein de
fringues très beau à Hollywood en même
temps
et dans le même temps et dans le même
temps il est en train il est en train de
divorcer avec ma mère donc vraiment il
se dit c'est un nouveau départ il arrive
à Los Angeles et au moment où il doit
commencer à tourner le on l'appelle
monsieur Castaldi il y a un problème il
commence à avoir ben non en fait vous
allez pas tourner parce que en fait vous
pouvez pas tourner vous avez pas
retourner un mecs parce que les
syndicats américains disent pourquoi
vous avez engagé un français elle
connaît ça alors que le rôle pouvait
tenu par un Américain donc on vous vire
donc il fait parler donc il est revenu
en France il avait pas touché son
oseille il avait le crédit il a revendu
les fringues et donc il est resté il est
resté 18 mots au chômage derrière et
toutes ces affaires il est dans sa
voiture il avait ramené parce qu'il
était en train de divorcer de ma mère on
lui a fracture la voiture on a tout
piqué donc il avait plus rien voilà
mon pays mon père c'est que ça on va on
va bien se marrer à mon avis
c'est parti sur
[Applaudissements]
il a un autre truc
Depardieu tous ces gens-là je ne
comédiens il signale un film avec Marcel
carnet alors les gens qui connaît ils
nous regardent
c'est un grand grand réalisateur du Nord
tout ça dure un grand et en fait mon
père est tout content de ça ce film là
et il rencontre son pote Depardieu et
lui dis toi tu fais quoi bah moi je
viens de signer avec carnet je vais pas
content donc lui faire du tabaron de la
chance parce que moi je viens de signer
un espèce de petit film de cul là ça
marchera jamais et c'était les valseuses
voilà non
de trajectoire
quand ton père alors oui il a ses
mouillé il avait un bonnet une moustache
et des lunettes noires on n'a jamais
reconnu dans le coin
non non
je sais pas quoi je crois que je te
demande de fermer ta gueule
avec ma grand-mère on était voir
pourquoi mon père et en fait on a vu
deux fois parce que on l'avait pas
reconnu non mais sérieux donc c'est
drôle ça c'est pas mal en fait
je mettrai pas un billet parce que
mais quoi mais j'achète déjà ma place
rien que pour voir Jean-Pierre parce que
c'est ton style Jean-Pierre
alors ce qui m'intéresse c'est que dans
20 ans Benjamin devrait être comme lui
donc
[Musique]
Daniel je peux te dire qu'elle en a
encore pour 60 70 ans
[Rires]
moi ça me donne bien envie